I'm going to be a mom that's right I'm
having a baby
no man a woman needs a man like a fish
needs a bicycle and all that
yes but I'm always like man we are quite
literally two women I just been thinking
I don't know what great need they may be
but not for yours
okay like I'm almost 40 I've stopped
eating happy divorce you very much oh
yeah
I hang on in there they need you to be
the person that you plan to be sooner
why because you're going to be another
the insemination program I've started
already
how could you do this in summation
clause 14 states
snap can you be without her no be easy
right
having a baby is just like having a man
around he's always pissed they just need
propping up now and again and give him
fluids let's be having some baby it
takes Amster who is the daddy daddy
yes you are she's pregnant you are going
to be a daddy I thought you meant
sexually I had sex with that I know it
was a baby gonna be coming over that
thank you for the biology lecture you
will be having a little baby boy I am
the father that little one needs a guide
we have a penis inside of me just time
for everything
hey why would you want him involved he
almost ruined us he's the father
okay chance we're talking about the man
who thought LGBT was just a really big
sandwich so you do when you're pregnant
you wear the each other like cabbies now
you know I love you don't you
I just think two women raising a child
together is disgusting
a tu was burned into Lisbon said only
took out spam well we'll be here when it
doesn't work out where we love
oh my gosh you're pregnant - oh my gosh
how did you guess
you